[Music]
please welcome to the stage president of
mathletes as well as their own self
published magazine women with a wide
valedictorian brandy Klark off the stage
virgin I loved high school I think I'm
in the minority I'm so really you did
yeah I love it
my name is Ellie Ashoka I play Fiona in
the film that to-do list I'm proud of it
it's a funny raunchy comedy wait you
just okay that's what I am sorry oh who
are you
great job finding the Aubrey Plaza again
and I play brandy Klark oh there you are
in the movie you should go from straight
A's you get in her first F that's right
I think it's sexy
but in an really unsexy way yes
well sir and I'm Maggie Carey I wrote
and directed the movie and I do pride
myself they are some of the most unsexy
sex scenes ever directed and so I nailed
that one
is it is this shorts or skirt neither
their sports she hated high school
diaries and they were helpful they gave
me a lot of inspiration you just had an
attitude and you're super confident like
it was very it was written from a person
that really knew everything and it was
very confident it was new everything
with Nokes no life experience that new
which is like you know most teenagers
we met at UCB theater in New York yeah a
long time ago we were in an improv class
together and we were friends
yeah and Maggie asked me to be in a web
series that she directed at the time
that I was in also with her husband Bill
Hader and some other people and
huh how am i yeah and I wrote the movie
with with Aubrey in mind that's why it's
sexy you know seen her do stuff at UCB
and seeing her in an improvised show
she'll play like six different
characters in the night and I love I
mean she definitely is amazing at
sarcastic and deadpan but it was fun to
also see or do something more Taipei and
very studious it's not having sex it's a
big deal is this smart growth plus
feelings and emotional crises a movie
okay that's why we're here that's enough
you're gonna love them go get it
your glasses on oh well I'm ready
[Music]